la parole est à monsieur jacques lamblin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur depuis des mois
en riches algérien monsieur nekkaz
s'efforce de rendre inopérante la loi
interdisant le port du voile intégral en
france
pour cela ils payent les amendes à la
place des contrevenantes
et le fait savoir à la france entière
pendant ce temps le gouvernement est
inerte voir complaisant
qu'on en juge vendredi dernier à toul la
france sidéré a pu voir votre police
bousculer madame morano députée
européenne et quelques personnes âgées
pour la plupart pour aider ce
provocateur
oui l'aider à récidiver pire encore
encouragé par cette victoire
bien décidé à vous narguer monsieur
nekkaz est venu hier à cherbourg c'est à
dire au coeur de votre fief monsieur
cazeneuve pour y payer encore une fois
une amende
toujours sous l'oeil de la police cette
nouvelle provocation est terrible car
elle est une gifle assénée publiquement
au ministre de l'intérieur
elle est vécue comme une humiliation par
tous les français quel est le résultat
de tout cela
faute d'avoir utilisé avec fermeté les
moyens que l'état d'urgence vous
accordais tel qu assignation en
résidence ou expulsion pour ce promoteur
de la burqa on voit aujourd'hui tout ce
que la france compte d'islamistes de
salafistes exulter pendant que des
millions de français serre les poings
monsieur le ministre vous ne pouvez
tolérer cette situation plus longtemps
sous peine de voir un fossé se creuser
et un face-à-face mortifère s'installer
en france allez vous oui ou non
redonner toute sa force à cette loi ce
serait l'honneur de la république pour
reprendre le propos de monsieur k p
merci la parole étant monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre
de l'intérieur monsieur l'emballage
partage tout à fait là l'antique et la
vaute de donner de la force et de
l'honneur à la république mais pour ça
il faut donner aussi de la force à la
vérité il y a juste un petit détail dans
votre question qui ne s'y trouve pas
mais qui est un petit détail qui fait
toute la différence c'est que le jour où
madame morano s'est interposé entre
monsieur nekkaz et la trésorerie
le sénat a adopté sur proposition de mon
ministère
un amendement par lequel désormais la
substitution à autrui pour le pas le
paiement des amendes
devenez interdisent que vous n'aviez pas
fait ce que j'ai fait avec mon ministère
précisément pour mettre fin à ce type de
pratique absolument inacceptable qui
n'ont pas lieu d'être dans la république
parce que précisément dans la république
nul ne peut se substituer à quiconque
doit payer une amende
ce qui était le cas jusqu'à présent qui
rendait cette loi inapplicable et celui
qui va rendre cette loi applicable par
le dépôt de cet amendement kate est
largement voté au sénat et qui j'en suis
sûr le sera largement voté à l'assemblée
nationale notamment par vous même et vos
amis j'en suis désormais convaincu
contenu de votre question c'est moi donc
le fait de ne pas avoir dit ça relève
d'une malhonnêteté intellectuelle
absolue et votre question me donne la
possibilité de rétablir les faits quant
à la fermeté vis-à-vis de tous ceux qui
portent l'islamisme radical en france et
vous rappeler un certain nombre de
choses extrêmement précise combien de
mosquées
avez-vous fermé lorsque vous étiez en
situation de responsabilité zéro et ceux
qui ont fermé des mosquées en utilisant
l'état d'urgence et la loi parce qu'on y
prônait des propos qui appelait provoqua
la haine c'est nous combien avez-vous
expulsé en cinq ans de personnes qui
appelait provoqué autoruns 15
nous en aurons expulsé près de 80 alors
monsieur lamblin dit à madame morano que
nous n'avons aucune leçon à recevoir en
la matière
merci